me encuentro frente al campo que los
inmigrantes y los griegos han comenzado
a llamar moria 2.0 justamente es el
campo de refugiados que el gobierno
griego ha instalado aquí en la isla para
intentar relocalizar a las casi 13.000
personas que vivían en el campo de moria
que se quemó hace justo tres semanas hoy
podemos visitar las ruinas de ese campo
donde todavía llegan migrantes buscando
algunas de sus pertenencias que se
salvaron de las llamas aquí detrás mío
muchos migrantes se negaron en un primer
momento a entrar sin embargo se dice que
ya hay casi 10.000 personas viviendo
allí viven en tiendas con poca
iluminación con algunas horas de agua al
día y sufren importantes controles a la
entrada para evitar que traigan
elementos cortantes o inflamables y
evitar un nuevo incendio las personas se
negaban a entrar no sólo por las
condiciones que critican solamente por
ejemplo tienen una ración de comida
diaria se les ha separado por
nacionalidades se ha aislado también a
muchos de ellos que tienen 19 sino que
también se negaban
no ven perspectivas muchos de ellos
llevaban meses viviendo aquí sin una
solución a su situación de asilo a sus
demandas por tener un estatuto de
refugiado en el 'viejo continente'